on may 27
2016
miss hurd walked into a courthouse in
los angeles california
to get a no notice x party restraining
order against mr depp
and in doing so
ruined his life
by falsely telling the world that she
was the survivor of domestic abuse at
the hands of mr depp
today
on may 27
2022
exactly six years
later we ask you to give mr depp his
life back
by telling the world that mr death is
not the abuser ms heard said he is
and hold miss heard accountable for her
lies now it's time for you
the jury
to come to a decision
you have been entrusted with a serious
task
what is at stake in this trial is a
man's good name
even more than that
what is at stake at this trial
is a man's life
the life that he lost when he was
accused of a heinous crime
and the life he could live when he was
finally vindicated
exactly six years ago today
on may 27 2016 ms hurd walked into court
and filed a false report of domestic
abuse against her husband of 15 months
johnny depp
the scene was a setup
she tipped off the paparazzi so they
would be waiting
they knew exactly where she would pause
which side of her face to photograph
and the photos captured what she wanted
them to see
the image of a battered woman
what the paparazzi did not know is that
the dark mark on her face mysteriously
appeared six days after last seen mr
depp
it was a lie
she knew it
mr depp knew it
and the multiple witnesses you heard
from who saw her that week of may 21
2016 also knew it
but the world only saw what she wanted
them to see
two years later
when promoting the biggest role of her
career
until this trial
ms hurd presented herself to the world
as a public figure representing domestic
abuse
the headline of the op-ed featured the
term sexual violence
even though she had never before accused
her ex-husband of such a heinous crime
ms hurd and her lawyers love to remind
you of how the op-ed did not mention mr
depp by name
but miss heard made sure that there
would be no mistake about who she was
referring to
she inserted
two years ago so the world would
remember the photo of a battered woman
the mark on her face standing outside
the courthouse
and they would once again see mr depp as
the villain
this time in full swing of the metoo
movement
but what was happening behind closed
doors was quite different from what ms
heard presented to the world
the exact opposite in fact
there is a there is an abuser in this
courtroom but it is not mr depp
and there is a victim of domestic abuse
in this courtroom but it is not misheard
the evidence presented at this trial has
shown that miss heard is in fact the
abuser and mr depp the abused
as you heard from mr depp and multiple
other witnesses that testified under
oath
at this trial
mr depp experienced persistent verbal
physical and emotional abuse
by misheard during their relationship
you heard from mr depp about how often
miss heard would berate him insult him
and physically attack him including one
of the most serious occasions when
misheard threw a vodka bottle at mr deb
severely injuring his finger and then
put a cigarette out on his face
you heard from mr depp that this whole
incident in australia started because
miss heard was enraged that mr depp
wanted a post-nuptial agreement and she
wasn't in his will
just a month after getting married
you also heard from tara roberts a
manager at mr duff's island who
witnessed miss heard telling mr deb that
he was washed up and would die fat and
lonely
you also heard from miss roberts that
she witnessed miss heard clawing and
grabbing at mr depp grabbing his hair
trying to pull him back to her and mr
depp had a visible injury to his nose on
that occasion
most importantly you heard from miss
heard yourselves
on multiple audio recordings admitting
to being physically violent with mr depp
what you didn't hear on a single
recording you heard in this case and
there were many played by both parties
is mr depp ever admitting to hitting
punching or kicking misheard
you didn't hear it
it doesn't exist
it didn't happen
and despite the fact that mr death and
misheard are heard discussing many of
the alleged incidents you've heard about
at this trial like australia and the
bahamas
you never heard miss heard accuse mr
depp of sexual assault
unlike mr depp who you heard admit to
and own up to his past mistakes and his
struggles particularly with drugs and
alcohol
miss heard will not admit that she has
never done that she has ever done
anything wrong
but she cannot deny what you heard on
those recordings
as much as miss heard and her lawyers
have tried to make this case about mr
depp's language
it is misheard that repeatedly admits to
violence
when you catch miss heard in a lie she
tries to cover it up with more lies
so let's talk about the giant lie at the
heart of this case
miss herd's claim that mr depp is an
abusive monster
and that she is a public figure
representing domestic abuse she spun a
story of shocking overwhelming brutal
abuse
she came into this courtroom prepared to
give the performance of her life and she
gave it misheard miss herd's acting
coach christina sexton testified that
miss heard has difficulty crying when
she is acting
you saw it
misheard sobbing without tears while
spinning elaborate exaggerated
fantastical accounts of abuse
and everything going on in her mind
almost a decade prior while enduring
that abuse
it was a performance what we have is a
mountain of unproven allegations that
are wild
over the top and implausible
and you can't pick and choose which of
these wild allegations to believe and
which ones to disregard
you either believe all of it or none of
it
either mr depp sexually assaulted
misheard with a bottle in australia
or misheard god up on that stand
in front of all of you
and made up that horrific tale of abuse
either she's a victim of truly horrific
abuse
or she is a woman who is willing to say
absolutely anything but this case
doesn't come down to whether you believe
misheard or you believe mr depp
this case comes down to whether you
believe miss heard
or you believe
mr depp
christy dombrowski
sean bett
malcolm connolly
travis mcgivern
starling jenkins
wyatt
dr kipper
nurses debbie lloyd and aaron filati
tara roberts
ben king
kate james
kate moss
dr colbert
morgan knight
morgan tremaine
officers melissa signs
officers tyler hadden
officer william gatlin
and beverly leonard
what ms heard testified to in this
courtroom is the story of far too many
women
but the overwhelming evidence
and weight of that evidence shows that
it's not her story
it's not miss heard's story
it was an act of profound cruelty not
just to mr depp but to true survivors of
domestic abuse
for miss heard to hold herself out as a
public figure representing domestic
abuse
it was false
it was defamatory and it caused
irreparable harm
and to talk more about that i'm going to
turn it over to my colleague and my
friend mr chu
as ms vasquez said
you have now come to know the real amber
heard
scary
we also told you at the start of this
trial that you were going to come to
know the real johnny depp
not
the many characters you've seen him play
so wonderfully in the movies but the man
himself
we kept that promise
you've met the real johnny depp before
amber heard ladies and gentlemen
no woman ever
no woman ever before amber heard ever
claimed that mr depp raised a hand to
her in his 58 years
and no other woman since
miss heard made that false claim back on
may 17 may 27 2016
has and repeated it in her december 2018
op-ed
has any woman come forward since
this is me too
without any me too
to the contrary ladies and gentlemen you
heard kate moss two days ago testify
this is a woman who has never
testified in any proceeding
ever
a very private person
testified that mr depp never abused her
and that miss heard lied to you and she
lied to you twice beyond the personal
and emotional effects of miss heard's
lies
their impact on mr depp and his family
the damage she inflicted on his
reputation and career is undeniable
there's an old saying that a good
reputation takes a lifetime to build
but only a second to destroy
mr depp spent in fact a lifetime
building his reputation as one of the
greatest actors and movie stars of his
generation an iconic figure respected
through and liked throughout hollywood
and recognized and admired throughout
the world as you heard in this case
amber heard is not a true victim and mr
depp certainly is not an abuser
again
nobody has come out of the woodwork to
say me too
this is the unique and singular me too
case where there's not a single
me too
while mr depp's name will be forever
tarnished by these horrendous and false
allegations
this case is about telling you his story
and the truth about what really happened
which you've now heard
it is about
restoring his lost reputation
it's about showing mr depp's children
lily rose and jack
that the truth is worth fighting for
it is
and it's about restoring mr depp's name
and standing in the community to the
fullest extent that you can and you can
do something
and only you ladies and gentlemen can do
that for him
you heard from mr depp yesterday
that he has been carrying these
outlandish outrageous stories on his
back
pretty stoically
and living them with them for six years
and waiting to be able to bring his
truth out and he has told you the truth
the unvarnished truth even truth that
pretty embarrassing he knew that was
going to happen when he brought this
case
you've seen the evidence in this case
over six long weeks which we again thank
you for
that evidence shows overwhelmingly that
miss heard's attempt to paint herself as
a heroic survivor
an innocent survivor
and mr depp as a terrifying abuser are
utterly
false
we ask you to please return your verdict
for mr death we ask you we implore you
to give him his name
his reputation and his career back thank
you very much ladies and gentlemen